A pesar de la enorme influencia de la religión en el mundo de hoy,
la mantenemos en un nivel diferente de escrutinio y rendición de cuentas
que cualquier otro sector de nuestra sociedad.
Por ejemplo, si hubiera una organización multinacional,
gobierno o corporación de hoy
que dijera que ninguna mujer puede estar en una junta directiva,
ninguna mujer puede tener poder de decisión,
ni tampoco una mujer puede manejar asuntos financieros,
nos provocaría indignación.
Habría sanciones.
Y, sin embargo, es una práctica común en casi todas las religiones del mundo.
Aceptamos cosas en nuestras vidas religiosas
que no aceptamos en nuestras vidas seculares,
y lo sé porque lo he estado haciendo durante tres décadas.
Era el tipo de chica que luchaba contra toda forma de discriminación de género.
Jugué partidos de baloncesto informales con chicos, marcando yo misma canastas.
Dije que sería la primera mujer presidente de EE.UU.
He luchado por la Enmienda de Igualdad de Derechos,
que ha estado muerta durante 40 años.
Soy la primera mujer en ambos lados de mi familia
que siempre trabajó fuera de casa y que tenía educación superior.
Nunca acepté ser excluida por ser mujer,
excepto en mi religión.
En todo ese tiempo,
era parte de una religión muy ortodoxa y patriarcal, la mormona.
Crecí en una familia sumamente tradicional.
Tengo ocho hermanos y una madre ama de casa.
Mi padre es en realidad un líder religioso en la comunidad.
Y yo crecí en un mundo creyendo que mi valor y mi estado
estaban en consonancia con estas reglas que yo había conocido toda mi vida.
Una se casa virgen, una nunca bebe alcohol,
no fuma, siempre es servicial.
una es una buena chica.
Algunas de las reglas que teníamos eran estrictas,
pero una seguía las reglas por amor a las personas
y por amor a la religión y a lo que una creía.
Todo lo referente al mormonismo decidía cómo me vestía,
con quién salía y debía casarme.
Decidía la ropa interior que llevábamos.
Yo era de una religión, donde todos los que conozco
donaban el 10 % de lo que ganaban a la iglesia,
incluida yo misma.
Del lo ganado por el buzoneo y por el cuidado de niños donaba el 10 %.
Yo era de la religión donde los padres dicen a los niños
que cuando los dejan en una misión de proselitismo de dos años
que prefieren que mueran
a que vuelvan a casa sin honor por haber pecado.
Yo era de esa religión
donde los niños se suicidan cada año
porque están aterrorizados de que salga a la luz que son gay en nuestra comunidad.
Pero también era de la religión
donde no importa en qué lugar del mundo viviera,
tenía amistad, ayuda mutua instantánea.
Aquí me sentía segura. Esta es la certeza y la claridad de la vida.
Tuve ayuda para criar a mi hija pequeña.
Así que por eso acepté sin dudas que solo los hombres pueden liderar,
y acepté sin discusión
que la mujer no tiene la autoridad espiritual de Dios en la Tierra,
lo que llamamos el sacerdocio.
Y permití discrepancias entre hombres y mujeres en presupuestos de funcionamiento,
en consejos disciplinarios, en la toma de decisiones,
y di a mi religión un pase libre
porque me encantaba.
Hasta que me detuve,
y me di cuenta de que yo había permitido que me trataran
como el personal de asistencia para el trabajo real de los hombres.
Y yo misma me enfrenté a esta contradicción,
y me sumé a otros activistas en mi comunidad.
Hemos trabajado muy, muy, muy arduamente en la última década y más.
Lo primero que hicimos fue aumentar la conciencia.
No puedes cambiar lo que no puedes ver.
Empezamos con el podcasting, blogs, a escribir artículos.
He creado listas de cientos de maneras
de que hombres y mujeres no son iguales en nuestra comunidad.
Lo siguiente que hicimos fue construir organizaciones de defensa.
Intentamos hacer cosas que eran rechazables
como llevar pantalones a la iglesia e intentar asistir a reuniones de hombres.
Parecen cosas simples,
pero para nosotras, las organizadoras, eran enormemente difíciles.
Perdimos relaciones. Perdimos puestos de trabajo.
Recibimos cartas de odio a diario.
Fuimos atacadas en los medios sociales y en la prensa nacional.
Recibimos amenazas de muerte.
Se nos ha excluido de nuestra comunidad. A algunas de nosotras nos excomulgaron.
A la mayoría nos hicieron un consejo disciplinario,
y las comunidades que amábamos nos rechazaron
porque queríamos mejorarlas, porque creíamos que era posible.
Y empecé a tener esa expectativa de mi propia gente.
Yo sé lo que se siente cuando alguien trata de cambiarte
o criticarte.
Pero lo que absolutamente me impactó a través de todo este trabajo
es recibir las misma críticas severas de la izquierda laica,
la misma vehemencia que la derecha religiosa.
Y lo que mis amigos seculares no vieron es que esta hostilidad religiosa,
estas frases de: "¡Todas las personas religiosas están locas o son estúpidas".
"No hagas caso a la religión".
"Ellos serán homófobos y machistas".
Lo que ellos no entendían
es que ese tipo de hostilidad no luchaba contra el extremismo religioso,
sino generaba extremismo religioso.
Esos argumentos no funcionan, y lo sé porque recuerdo
a los que me decían que yo era estúpida por ser mormón.
Y lo que hizo que me defendiera a mí y a mi gente
y todo lo que creemos, porque no somos estúpidos.
La crítica y la hostilidad no funcionan, y no escuchaba estos argumentos.
Cuando oigo estos argumentos, todavía me sigo erizando,
porque tengo familia y amigos.
Esta es mi gente y soy la primera en defenderlos,
pero la lucha es real.
¿Cómo respetamos la creencia religiosa de alguien
sin dejar de hacerlos responsables por el daño o perjuicio
que esas creencias pueden causar en otros?
Es una pregunta difícil. Todavía no tengo la respuesta perfecta.
Mis padres y yo hemos caminado en esta cuerda floja la última década.
Son personas inteligentes. Son gente encantadora.
E intentaré ayudarles a entender su perspectiva.
En el mormonismo, creemos que, después de la muerte,
si uno sigue todas las reglas y todos los rituales,
uno puede estar como familia juntos nuevamente.
Y para mis padres, hacer algo tan simple
como vestir un top sin mangas ahora, mostrando los hombros,
me hace indigna.
No estaré con mi familia para la eternidad.
Pero es más, un hermano mío murió en un trágico accidente a los 15,
y algo tan simple como esto significa que no estaremos juntos como familia.
Y mis padres no pueden entender
por qué algo tan simple como la moda o los derechos de las mujeres
me impediría ver a mi hermano.
Y esa es la mentalidad a la que nos enfrentamos,
y la crítica no cambia eso.
Y así, mis padres y yo hemos caminado en esta cuerda floja,
explicando nuestra postura, respetándonos los unos a los otros,
pero en realidad invalidar creencias básicas de cada uno
por la forma de vivir nuestras vidas ha sido difícil.
La forma de hacerlo
es deshaciéndonos de esos proyectiles defensivos
y realmente ver el interior suave de la incredulidad y la fe
y tratar de respetar a los demás, mientras se mantienen límites claros.
Otra cosa que la izquierda secular, los ateos y los ortodoxos
y la derecha religiosa, lo que todos ellos no entienden
es por qué preocuparse por el activismo religioso.
No puedo decir cuantos cientos de personas me han dicho,
"Si no te gusta la religión, salte de ella".
¿Por qué tratar de cambiarla?
Porque lo que se enseña en el Sabbath
transciende a nuestra política, a nuestra política de salud,
la violencia en todo el mundo.
Permea la educación, el ejército, la toma de decisiones fiscal.
Estas leyes están codificadas legal y culturalmente.
De hecho, mi propia religión ha tenido un enorme efecto en esta nación.
Por ejemplo, durante la Proposición 8, mi iglesia recaudó más de USD 22 millones
para luchar contra el matrimonio de personas del mismo sexo en California.
Hace 40 años, los historiadores políticos decían
que de no ser por la oposición mormona a la Enmienda de Igualdad de Derechos,
tendríamos una Enmienda de Igualdad de Derechos en nuestra Constitución hoy.
¿A cuántas vidas afectó eso?
Y podemos pasar tiempo luchando por cada una
de estas pequeñas leyes y normas diminutas,
o podemos preguntarnos:
¿por qué existe la desigualdad de género por omisión en todo el mundo?
¿Por qué se asume?
Porque la religión no se limita a crear las raíces de moral,
sino que crea semillas de normalidad.
Las religiones pueden liberar o subyugar,
pueden potenciar o explotar, pueden consolar o destruir,
y la gente que inclina la balanza hacia la ética y la moral
a menudo no es responsable.
Las religiones no pueden ser destituidas o ignoradas.
Tenemos que tomarlas en serio.
Pero no es fácil influir en una religión, como acabamos de decir.
Pero les diré lo que ha hecho mi gente.
Mis grupos son pequeños, somos cientos de personas,
pero hemos tenido gran impacto.
Ahora en los pasillos cuelgan imágenes de mujeres
junto a la de los hombres por primera vez.
Ahora a las mujeres se les permite orar en las reuniones en toda la iglesia,
y antes nunca estaban en asambleas generales,
hasta la semana pasada en una decisión histórica,
invitaron a tres mujeres de liderazgo
que supervisan toda la iglesia.
Hemos visto cambios de percepción en la comunidad mormona
que permiten hablar de la desigualdad de género.
Hemos abierto el espacio, independientemente de ser rechazadas,
para las mujeres más conservadoras que intervienen y hacen cambios reales,
y "mujeres" y "sacerdocio" se pueden pronunciar ahora en la misma frase.
Nunca tuve eso.
Mi hija y mis sobrinas están heredando una religión que nunca tuve,
ahora es más igualitaria, ha surtido efecto.
No fue fácil posicionarse,
tratar de entrar en esas reuniones masculinas.
Había cientos de nosotras,
y una por una, al llegar a la puerta,
escuchó: "Lo siento, esta reunión es solo para hombres"
y tuvimos que dar un paso atrás y ver a los hombres entrar a la reunión
teniendo tan solo 12 años,
escoltados y pasando ante nosotras, cuando estábamos de pie en fila.
Pero ni una sola mujer en esa fila olvidará ese día,
y ningún niño que pasó por delante de nosotras olvidará ese día.
Si hubiéramos sido una corporación multinacional o gobierno, lo sucedido
habría despertado indignación,
pero somos solo una religión.
Todos somos solo una parte de las religiones.
No podemos seguir mirando la religión de esa manera,
porque no solo me afecta, afecta a mi hija
y a todas sus hijas y las oportunidades que tienen,
lo que pueden vestir, a quién pueden amar y con quién casarse,
si tienen acceso a servicios de salud reproductiva.
Tenemos que recuperar la moral en un contexto secular
que cree escrutinio ético y responsabilidad
para las religiones de todo el mundo,
pero tenemos que hacerlo de manera respetuosa
que engendre la cooperación y no el extremismo.
Y podemos hacerlo a través de actos reconocibles de valentía,
defendiendo la igualdad de género.
Es hora de que la mitad de la población mundial
tenga voz e igualdad en las religiones del mundo,
en iglesias, sinagogas, mezquitas y santuarios de todo el mundo.
Estoy trabajando por mi gente. ¿Qué hacen Uds. por la suya?
(Aplausos)